SETH VARGO: Hi there.
And welcome to our 10th
episode on SRE and DevOps.
My name is Seth and I'm
a developer advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And I'm Liz,
a site reliability engineer
at Google where I teach Google
Cloud customers how to build
and operate reliable services.
So I've just wrapped
up an incident.
And I definitely don't want
to have the same set of things
happen in the exact same ways.
What should I do to learn?
SETH VARGO: So Liz, you want to
conduct a blameless postmortem
or retrospective.
There are a few key things that
go into every retrospective,
but there are a variety of ways
of collecting that information.
First, you'll need
some basic metadata,
like what systems were
affected and what humans
were involved in that process.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
It doesn't make sense to conduct
a postmortem without involving
everyone who played a part.
SETH VARGO: Right.
And then you need to start
assembling any records
that you have and start to
begin understanding a timeline,
like, how did we find
out about the event?
When did we start responding?
What mitigations did we
deploy, either temporarily
or permanently?
When did the incident
actually conclude?
And it's important
to note that this
is a collaborative process.
Initially, the draft is written
by the incident commanders
but all participants
collaborate and add
their relevant information.
It's usually helpful to
use a collaborative tool
like Google Docs for this step.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I'm
starting to understand now
why you emphasized the role of
the planning lead last time.
It's definitely a lot
easier to [? coord ?] things
as you go rather than having
to piece everything together
after the fact.
SETH VARGO: And you'll also need
to understand what things you
did that you'll need to
roll back or clean up
afterwards, things like
temporarily increasing
the size of a VM or directing
traffic away from a zone.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
can definitely see
how it could get expensive or
risky if I didn't put those
back the way that I found them.
SETH VARGO: But most
importantly in the process,
though, is making sure that
you have a blameless culture,
ensuring that people feel like
they won't be faulted or fired
for the mistakes that
they may have made.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
definitely see how
I'd be really reluctant
to say, I messed up,
if I were afraid of
being fired or ridiculed.
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
And participating
in a postmortem
is a learning opportunity
for everyone involved,
including the company, not
some kind of punishment.
And it works best
if your team can
think about the possibility
of a well-intentioned human
to cause a system failure
as a bug in the system,
not as a bug in the human.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
You can't fix humans.
SETH VARGO: It's often helpful
to ask questions like, "what
did you know at the time"
or "how did the system
behave" as opposed to "why
did you restart the process"
in order to avoid putting
people on the defensive.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
So how do you actually
organize this information
once you're
collecting it though?
SETH VARGO: So
every organization
has different ways
for communicating.
As I said above,
at Google, we tend
to use Google Docs and comments.
Other organizations
may prefer something
like a live conference
bridge with someone
taking notes in the background.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
That makes sense.
And you reminded
me by mentioning
taking notes during an
audio only conference bridge
that it's not really a great
idea to, during an incident,
having audio only conference
bridges because you have
to have someone
record very detailed
notes in order to reconstruct
what happened after the fact.
But we haven't really
gotten to anything
about how do we prevent the
root cause from happening again.
SETH VARGO: Well, be
careful there, Liz.
Remember that failures in
distributed systems almost
never have a single root cause.
It's usually more than
one contributing factor
that's causing an
intersection or some kind
of cascading failure.
So you'll want to write down
everything that contributed
to this abnormal behavior
instead of just trying
to identify the root cause.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So what
I should be focusing on
is how do I mitigate
individual kinds of failures
and how do I prevent
them from intersecting
in these same ways.
SETH VARGO: Right.
And then you'll want to keep
track of that is explicitly
filing an issue in your
issue tracker of choice
for each action
item so that you'll
make sure to prioritize
it for the future.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And I can
definitely tag these things
with the postmortem
tag in my bug tracker
so I can see how at risk I am
of repeat outages based off
of how many high priority
items that I've checked off
and how many remain outstanding.
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
And you'll also want to capture
some overall themes like what
went well, what went
poorly, and, honestly, what
did we just get lucky with.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I also
imagine that recognizing
people that went
above and beyond
and systems that worked
well and worked as designed
is a good positive
motivator as well.
SETH VARGO: Exactly.
And one last key thing
to keep track of,
once you understand the
incident in its entirety,
is to write down machine
readable metadata
so that you can
track improvements
to your overall incident
response management process
over time, such as decreasing
the total time to resolve
incidents, or knowing whether
a release was involved,
or a cascading failure, or
config changes, et cetera.
This can help you identify
meta patterns in your outages
and build either
process or technology
to help prevent or mitigate
those incidents in the future.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And that's
where Google statistics come
from that approximately
70% of our outages
are from binary
configuration changes,
because we've been
recording that metadata
over the past seven years.
SETH VARGO:
Hopefully, these tips
help you prepare for
your next incident.
And thanks to everyone for
watching this series so far.
Please write to us
on Twitter if you
have feedback or suggestions
for future topics.
Thank you for watching.
Please be sure to like
and subscribe below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]